bienvenue à hampton inn avez-vous une
réservation non
c'est qu'un chien dans votre sac non
nous autorisons en fait les petits animaux domestiques avec un
dépôt de garantie bien parce que j'ai un
petit chien
dans mon véhicule
que faites-vous dans le mercure ou
vous reculez ou de  bien sûr pas dégoûtant
et voici l'affaire mon pote slade et moi
sommes censés être ensemble et je suis ici pour le
récupérer je suis presque sûr qu'il est
marié avec un enfant sur le chemin aucun enfant n'est
ici je suis cool avec ça  je veux dire que j'ai
des bagages aussi je garderais tout cela pour
moi je trouverais un
thérapeute
que son nouveau bébé est juste chéri l'as-
tu vu
de près
tu sais quoi oh mon dieu
c'est une ancienne ambassadrice
dieu toi  sont un travail puis-je
vous aider à trouver quelque chose je vais
à un concert de rock avec une vieille flamme
montrons-lui ce qu'il a manqué non il m'a
vu récemment il sait
que sa femme ne m'a pas vu depuis un moment
alors
tu  peut venir en ville avec moi comme nous avons
toujours prévu mavis je suis un homme marié nous
pouvons battre ce truc ensemble